if you replace your body with a machine
are you still human
is it possible to maintain individualism
without any human parts maybe that
individualism is actually what creates
Humanity in us
see dpr has always been a company that
put a very big emphasis on the story
storytelling and creating very strong
emotion and players with cyberpunk we're
adding a whole new sort of pillar to it
which is what we call open-ended
gameplay we have non-linearity and
storytelling non-linearity and the way
you explore the world and now we want to
introduce non-linearity in gameplay you
can play your character any way we would
like to play it I like to complete
missions in a way that I have managed to
outsmart my opponents in the matter what
game it is I always play big butch
characters that kind of pull out for
everything and all these things have an
effect on how your story plays out
Chinese sovereignty good morning night
Sita the song on the radio is by rocker
boy Johnny silvery Johnny silver hand
who's a legend and Knight City a
musician but also an activist we were
creating this character as we were in
the process we realized hey would be
really cool if Keanu Reeves could play
this character piano is amazing
Johnny silver handle will be our
player's guide to the cities with you
for most of the game wake up Samurai
we have a city to burn this project is
of a scale that we've never tackled
before the ambition is crazy
something like stadia really allows more
people to experience our stories
everyone gets to experience the same
awesome story question locations it's a
very technologically demanding game but
with the stadia you can actually play it
respectively or the power of your
devices there are many scenes that
people are gonna have very strong
feelings about I hope that the lens of
the game and the lens of the future will
show them in an exaggerated way things
that are already happening in our
society and hopefully our future is
gonna be better than the grim future of
cyberpunk 2077
[Music]